SANDEEP DINESH: Everyone
knows it's a good idea
to keep your application
dependencies up to date.
Kubernetes and Docker can make
these updates much easier,
as you can build a new container
with the updated dependencies
and deploy it with
relative ease.
Just like your
application dependencies,
Kubernetes is constantly getting
new features and security
updates.
So the underlying nodes and
Kubernetes' infrastructure
needs to be kept
up to date as well.
In this episode of
"Kubernetes Best Practices,"
let's take a look at
how Google Kubernetes
Engine can make upgrading your
Kubernetes cluster painless.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When it comes to
upgrading your cluster,
there are two parts that
need to be upgraded--
the masters and the nodes.
The masters need to
be updated first,
and then the nodes can follow.
Let's see how to upgrade both
using Google Kubernetes Engine.
Google Kubernetes Engine
will automatically
upgrade the master as point
releases are released.
However, it usually won't
upgrade to a new version--
for example, 1.7 to
1.8 automatically.
When you're ready to
upgrade to a new version,
you can just click
the Upgrade Master
button in the GKE console.
However, you may have
noticed that the dialog
box has the following.
Changing the master version
can result in several minutes
of control plane downtime.
During that period, you'll be
unable to edit this cluster.
Wow, OK.
So when the master goes
down for the upgrade,
deployments, and services, and
the all that normal Kubernetes
stuff will continue
to work as expected.
However, anything that
requires the Kubernetes API
will stop working.
So this means [? QPTL ?]
will sop working,
applications that use
the Kubernetes API to get
information about the
cluster will stop working,
and basically, you can't make
any changes to the cluster
while it's being upgraded.
So how do you update the
master with zero downtime?
While the standard zonal
GKE cluster can only
have one master
backing them, you
can actually create
regional clusters
that provide multi-zone
high-availability masters.
So when creating
your cluster, be
sure to select the
regional option.
And that's it.
Your nodes and masters
will automatically
be created in three
zones, and the masters
will be behind a
load-balanced IP address.
So the Kubernetes
API will continue
to work during an upgrade.
When upgrading nodes, there
are a few different strategies
that you can use.
There's two that I
want to focus on--
rolling updates, and
migration using node pools.
The simplest way to update
your Kubernetes nodes
is using a rolling update.
This is the default
upgrade mechanism
that GKE uses to
update your nodes.
A rolling update works
in the following way.
One by one, a node is
drained and cordoned
so that there are no more
pods running on that node.
Then the node is
deleted, and the new node
is created with the
updated Kubernetes version.
Once that node is
up and running,
the next node is updated,
and so on and so forth,
until all the nodes are updated.
You can let GKE manage
this process for you
completely by enabling automatic
node upgrades on the node pool.
Now, if you don't
select this option,
the GKE dashboard will alert you
when an upgrade is available.
Just click the link,
follow the prompts,
and you'll begin
your rolling update.
It's important to make
sure your pods are managed
by a replica set, deployment,
stateful set, or something
similar.
Standalone pods
won't be rescheduled.
So while a rolling update
is simple to perform on GKE,
it does have a few drawbacks.
One drawback is you
actually get one less node
of capacity in your cluster.
While it's updating,
that node is
being taken out of commission.
But this issue is easily solved
by scaling up your node pool
to add extra capacity,
and then scaling it
back down once the
upgrade is finished.
Also, the fully automated
nature of the rolling update
makes it easy to do, but
you have less control
over the process.
So if something goes wrong
and you had to rollback,
it takes time to roll
back to the old version,
because you have to
stop the rolling update
and then undo it.
So now let's look at how
you can use multiple node
pools to upgrade your cluster.
So instead of upgrading
the active node pool,
as you would with
the rolling update,
you create a brand
new fresh node pool,
wait for all the
nodes to be running,
and then migrate workloads
over one node at a time.
Because you're running
these commands yourself,
you have more control over
the migration process.
But GKE is still managing
the nodes for you.
So let's assume that our
Kubernetes cluster has
three VMs right now.
You can see the nodes
with the get node command.
To create a new node
pool with the name
pool two, run the
following command.
Remember to customize
this command
so the new node pool is
the same as the old pool.
You can also use the
GUI to create a new node
pool if you want.
Check out the link
for more information.
So now if you check
the nodes, you'll
notice that there's three more
nodes with the new pool name.
However, the pods will
still be on the old nodes.
So let's move them over.
We need to move pods
to the new node pool.
Let's move over one node at
a time in a rolling fashion.
First, cordon each
of the old nodes.
This will prevent new pods
from being scheduled onto them.
Once all the old
nodes are cordoned,
pods can only be scheduled
onto the new nodes.
This means you can start to
remove pods from the old nodes,
and Kubernetes will
automatically schedule them
onto the new nodes.
Then we need to drain each node.
So this will delete all
the pods on that node.
After you drain a node,
make sure the new pods
are up and running before
moving on to the next one.
If you have any issues
during migration,
uncordon the old pool, and then
cordon and drain the new pool.
And so the pods
will automatically
get rescheduled back
to the old pool.
Once all the pods are
safely rescheduled,
it's just time to
delete the old pool.
Replace default-pool with
the pool you want to delete.
By using Google
Kubernetes Engine,
you can keep your
Kubernetes cluster up
to date with just a few clicks.
I highly recommend using
GKE regional clusters
for the high-availability
masters,
and using automatic
node upgrades
to have a hassle-free
upgrade experience.
If you need extra control
for your node updates,
using node pools
gives you that control
without giving up the advantages
of the manage platform
that GKE gives you.
If you're not using a
manage service like GKE,
you can still use a rolling
update or node pools method
with your own cluster
to upgrade nodes.
The difference is, you need
to manually add the new nodes
to your cluster and
perform the master upgrades
yourself, which can be tricky.
I'll see you on the next episode
of "Kubernetes Best Practices."
[MUSIC PLAYING]